salut c'est Olivier d'avant qui va te
donner ton premier grand rôle dans le
téléfilm frère la roulette rouge on est
en 94 tu te rappelles de ça ou pas tu as
33 ans ouais la roulette rouge
[Musique]
va te faire voir lui c'est qui lui c'est
le pilote c'est le pilote lui il a pas
une tranche de pilote il a une tranche
de boulanger tu me charges ou quoi
tu me fais rire ah je te fais rire
[Applaudissements]
et c'est Luc Besson grâce à Luc que
j'aurai d'ailleurs Lucie je crois pas
qu'il nous regarde ce soir parce que je
crois que je crois pas qu'il soit à
Paris mais je fais des bisous c'est
grâce à Luc Besson tu vas devenir une
énorme star ta carrière d'école d'un
seul coup de manière fulgurante taxi 98
c'est un des plus grands succès du
cinéma français 12 millions d'entrées on
va regarder un petit extrait pour le
kiff quand tu revois taxi ça te fait
toujours quelque chose ou pas bien sûr
parce que je vois le travail qui a été
accompli avec les années puis le travail
avec Luc ouais il nous a pas lâché qui
voulait qu'on apprenne notre texte par
cœur parce que c'était des films
quand ta tournée taxi tu t'es dit ça va
être un truc de fou comme ça ou pas je
savais qu'avec Luc Besson j'étais dans
une grosse machine et quoi qu'il arrive
je savais que j'allais vivre une
aventure extraordinaire et puis on a
fait une doublette ça a été un succès et
j'ai vécu une aventure extraordinaire
sur le 1 le 2 le 3 et le 4 quoi bien sûr
regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
7 minutes 32 merci pour la course merci
pour le spectacle
après succès incroyable est-ce qu'à un
moment après succès tu as pété un câble
tu as dit ouais je suis devenu une
énorme star c'était bien sûr que
c'est difficile parce que
moi je vais raconter juste une anecdote
depuis des années
Sami a été pas plus vieux que moi
d'ailleurs et j'avais produit déjà trois
films avec lui et un jour j'arrive à mon
bureau il y avait trois étages tout ça
je monte et puis je vois que toutes les
affiches sont signés
j'arrive dans mon bureau et je vois
assez à ma place j'ai mes amis qu'est-ce
que tu fais là il me dit non non mais
c'est foutu pigeois un paquet cadeau et
tout je joue ce paquet cadeau un stylo
quartier je dis mais attends et on est
pas de trucs tous les deux donc même si
on produisait des films on était
vraiment des crevards et je dis mais
attends mais Sami il me dit ah mais ça
sent tout est foutu maintenant c'est
foutu tu comprends je vais faire le taxi
je commence à tu vas faire le taxi lui
croyait que j'allais travailler à la G7
mais tu comprends rien c'est pas c'est
pas je vais faire le taxi je vais
travailler avec pires et je vais faire
taxi et en fait ce que je trouve
extraordinaire c'est qu'il avait déjà la
pression qu'à la fois ça va être quelque
chose d'extraordinaire qui allait faire
qu'on allait se quitter mais en même
temps quelque chose qui allait aussi
être sa chute à travers tout son tout
cette expérience parce que quand on va
là haut on va aussi un peu en bas et
donc ça c'était mais par contre on s'est
retrouvé quoi allez 30 ans plus tard le
25 ans plus tard je sais plus et là
voilà on fait plein de choses tu savais
ouais tu savais que ça parce que tout à
l'heure ça m'a ça m'a un peu tu m'as
envoyé un peu de d'émotion ça m'a
rappelé des choses c'est monter trop
vite
quand tu pètes tout d'un coup et tu es
pas préparé à ça quand tu es pas entouré
ce que je disais j'ai fait deux trois ma
masterclass là avec des jeunes et tout
ça si c'est pas entouré de ta famille
de gens solides autour de toi pas des
des tu sais moi Cyril que tu as tous les
jours on envoie des pics assiettes des
gens et si tu as pas des vrais gens
autour de toi tu montes et tu pètes tout
parce que ça va trop vite ça monte d'un
coup et moi je suis monté super vite et
d'un coup j'ai rien compris et après
après tu écoutes pas vraiment tout ça tu
crois que ben non et puis tu glisses
mais voilà après si on a chacun notre
parcours et notre chemin de croix et
aujourd'hui grâce à Dieu on vient de
ouais
téléspectateurs te voir à chaque fois je
sais que c'est un bonheur qui sait
comment tu as c'est vrai que je sais que
te sucer engendrer beaucoup de jalousie
aussi à l'époque tu as comme tu dis tu
es monté hyper vite quoi les gens
étaient jaloux les gens te te aussi
ouais c'est quoi tu avais des mecs qui
et puis tu fais des jaloux toi tu fais
des jaloux je veux dire quand tu as du
succès tu jalouse les gens en France en
France contrairement à d'autres pays
on le succès il fait
une jalousie et puis et puis si tu
dérapes nous en plus
des origines qu'on a on a moins le droit
à l'erreur qu'aux autres on doit être
vraiment irréprochable et si tu fais une
boulette toi il faut que il faut que
vraiment tu fasses attention un autre
qui va être qui va pas avoir les mêmes
origines que toi il va faire une
boulette bon ça va pas être pris pareil
on va essayer de l'effacer un petit peu
on va pas citer de Blaze mais voilà et
aujourd'hui ce qui compte c'est quoi
c'est le professionnelisme
qui ont fait qui ont fait des des
erreurs mais qui ont été moins voilà
bien sûr
on va pas citer non mais bien sûr toi tu
penses qu'on a pris dans la gueule pour
moi ouais ouais et puis bon après c'est
pas grave aujourd'hui ça tu considères
que tu as pété les plombs ou pas
ouais je pense que aussi j'ai fait des
erreurs des erreurs de jeunesse des
erreurs de gamins que ceux-ci mais ce
qui compte c'est quoi c'est que je sois
alors sur le tournage que je connaisse
peut-être par cœur que si je fais des
conneries c'est en dehors du tournage et
quand je suis quand tu m'emplois bah je
suis je suis là je te donne ce que tu
veux à toi le réalisateur toi le
producteur tu prends de l'oseille avec
moi tu gagnes ta vie alors ok mais non
on peut pas alors ok c'est vrai que
après tu as la ligne de conduite comme
les footballeurs faut être propre sur
soi ceci cela parce que tu représentes
la France machin nanani nanana mais
après
tant que tu gagnes de l'oseille avec moi
et que je fais ton métier et que je suis
à l'heure et que je pars après les
techniciens alors arrête d'inventer des
légendes des trucs des machins voilà là
on vient Éric vient de nous trouver des
producteurs américains on a un mécène de
français de la Côte d'Azur qui est là
qui croit en 5000 la série qui croit au
travail de Samy Naceri qui croit en
l'écriture de Bibi la série
et qui avec nous et qui s'en bat les
couilles de ce qu'il y a eu avant et qui
regarde devant il mise sur nous il met
de l'oseille sur nous et on vient de
produire on produit un seul en scène on
va faire l'adaptation de ce bouquin qui
est un peu un style Roger Rabbit avec
des humains et il y a des cartoons il y
a des fila il y a plusieurs films en
préparations
je veux dire c'est un garçon qui
travaille dur tous les jours il est au
travail pour son parce que faut pas
croire à faire des films c'est
sympathique de les regarder mais faire
des films c'est dur et chaque fois qu'on
fait un film c'est quand même un miracle
de d'avoir trouvé des financements
d'avoir trouvé des logiques qui qu'il
faut que le film il existe et et et et
Sandy bah ça ça c'est un gars ça c'est
un gars du voyage d'ailleurs salut toute
la communauté du voyage par la même
occasion et et et et et et et c'est un
mec est en train de devenir un vrai
metteur en scène mais là pour revenir ce
que sur ce que disait Sami de toute
façon c'est un accompagnement je veux
dire faire ce métier seul c'est très
difficile on a besoin de gens alors ça
peut être moi le producteur ça peut être
ça peut être un ami se mettre une femme
ça peut être peu importe qui se peut
être un argent mais en tout cas il faut
un accompagnant qui est qui est positif
pour la personne et qui le connaît et ça
c'est très important et et et Sandy il a
trouvé sa famille d'ailleurs avec toi il
a il a il a un rapport énorme il t'adore
il espère que tu fasses son film et si
tu veux quand vous en avez parlé hier et
c'est vrai que ça c'est quelque chose de
très très important